[Music]
foreign
part two of my interview with former
president Trump at Mar-A-Lago we
discussed Biden's weakness on the world
stage and the danger and the alliance
between China and Russia and how real it
is take a look
I will tell you my view that this is
worse and far worse let's look at for
example president XI let's look at
Vladimir Putin they meet they discuss
their great friendship and how they have
an opportunity that the world is not
seen in a hundred years China Brokers a
deal with Iran and Saudi Arabia they're
about to broker another deal with Saudi
Arabia and Syria then we watched the
China spy balloon incident uh you know
to go down over the Skies of Alaska down
the west coast of Canada Idaho over our
missile silos in Montana Missouri Kansas
Kentucky out the Carolinas then we shoot
it down then we see Russia take down one
of our drones
I would argue there is emerging in real
time
in this world as we speak a new axis of
Evil and it is ambition territorial
ambition we see it for example you know
Belarus is supposed to now be taking on
uh nuclear nuclear weapons from Putin
okay they're aligned you know how far
does his territorial Ambitions go
that'll be next by the way okay nuclear
weapons that'll be next China
Russia Iran the Saudis have left the
Coalition that you had put together
and then you have your buddy Little
Rocket Man back in Action now that to me
would be a powerful axis of Evil why is
that happening and what would you have
done with the balloon and what would you
have done if Putin took down one of your
drones I wouldn't have done anything
with the balloon because it wouldn't
have happened under me wouldn't happen
they wouldn't have sent the balloon if
this is a big balloon this is a balloon
where you can see it from it's like
three bucks 75 000 feet away people are
looking but it's strange they see it up
there we only found out because of a guy
in Montana they wouldn't have done it
I'm just telling you just like Putin
would have never gone into Ukraine I
used to talk to him about it I said
better do it better not do it and he
wouldn't have known we had a very
friendly conversation about it I said
hey Vladimir you had to explain you
can't go into Ukraine why are you say it
with such conviction why if you were
president would they not have done this
because he knew nothing around with us
but they fear you I don't want to say
that you know why because you'd say oh I
don't like people to say oh they fear me
like a schmuck
I don't want to say it but did they fear
me I suspect they did and you know what
uh Putin I ended his pipeline you never
heard of Nordstrom 2 until I came along
I started speaking about Nordstrom too
don't seem to is their pipeline the
biggest pipeline in the world they're
building it to Germany I gave Germany
the white flag of surrender I sent it to
Uncle I said Angela the great story I
have a white flag of surrender but why
why dude because you've fought
historically lots of wars with Russia
and now they're supplying they're going
to supply 80 percent of your energy
I said Angela are you crazy are you
crazy she also LED millions of people
into our country which has you know
perhaps permanently screwed up her
country but look at this this leg
little let anyone know remember I made
the speech at the United Nations and the
German
delegation was smiling and laughing they
thought it was so funny when I said
Germany should not have made a deal with
Russia on nordstream 2 on a pipeline
supplying their energy and these guys
were all laughing they're not laughing
anymore those guys got fired for being
stupid and it was just common sense that
you can't do that Germany can't do that
they made that deal Sean it was it was
absolutely one of the dumbest deals but
that's when Putin said boy you're
killing me
and then they go and I gave them
javelins by the way you know the
javelins that wiped out all the tanks
Obama gave them sheets
and I gave them javelins I was the one
that gave him javelins those javelins
knocked out all the tanks but Putin said
to me man you're killing me
especially about Nordstrom because that
was and I stopped it it was stopped cold
and I told other countries if you go
into the north shame deal you're not
going to do any business with the United
States of America meaning rip us off on
trade because most of them have ripped
us off I made a lot of great trade deals
I changed a lot of those deals where it
was a bad deal for us now it's a good
like U.S MCA with NATO I got rid of NATO
and built usmca I made a great track
deal with China our farmers are to this
day they've made tremendous money
because of the deal but because of covet
I don't even talk about that deal
because that overrid you know overrode
everything but when you look at what I
did and a lot of it's common sense you
know a lot of people say are you a
conservative are you this I said I'm a
person yeah I'm conservative and I'm a
person with a lot of common sense and I
also get things done
Putin would have never gone in she would
never have gone and you know we don't
know yet but looks like he's getting
ready to do something with Taiwan it
wasn't even discussed
is there really any doubt about Taiwan
because I don't really have any doubt
well there was I think they were
calculating that Biden won't lift a
finger he knew there was going to be
massive retaliation and it was done with
the mouth there was no blood spilled
if I were president that would have
never happened in Russia Afghanistan you
know I'm the one that got it down to
2500 Soldiers the problem they did is
they moved the military out before they
moved the people up so if you cover
better than anybody else we have a lot
of American citizens right now in
Afghanistan excuse me blinken testified
last week 175 and last week admitted
that some of them are hostages for the
first time there's no media on that now
that was to take the military Outlast
and they were afraid of our military I
didn't lose one person 18 months
I didn't lose one person in 18 months
and I had a conversation with Abdul he
was the leader of the Taliban everyone
oh I was criticized so badly by the fake
news media why are you you know Jesse
James was a bank robbery he was very
good at it they said why do you always
go well rob banks he said that's where
the money is they said why are you
talking to Abdul I said I'm talking to
Abdul because he's the head of the
Taliban and they're killing our people
and I said Abdul
if you kill one more person we're going
to hit you harder than anybody's ever
Joe Biden said to this country he
wouldn't leave a single American behind
Tony blinken testified last week that
there were 175 Americans and and many
are hostages why did they keep that from
us for so long all right but I want to
move on because I could talk to you
about this all day
um just to finish on it was the worst
and most embarrassing decision in my
opinion not getting out because I want
to get I would have been out before them
it was the most embarrassing the way
they got out we would have gotten out
with strength and dignity and we would
have kept Bagram Air Base which is the
biggest runway most powerful runways
anywhere in the world and the reason
isn't Afghanistan the reason it was one
hour away away from where China makes
its nuclear missiles so it would have an
air base right next to where China makes
and you know who's occupying it now
China